Let's get started setting up our virtual camera in Unreal Engine.
First thing you'll need of course is a computer running Unreal Engine.
Next we'll need either an iPad Pro, which is recommended, but an iPhone X or later can
also be used.
And then you'll want the LiveLink Vcam app installed on your phone.
This is a free app in the iOS app store.
You can also download the Unreal Remote 2 app as a backup in case you run into issues here,
but hopefully will have success with the Vcam app.
Over in Unreal, we'll want to enable the virtual camera plugin, which by its nature will actually
activate the LiveLink and Pixel streaming plugins when you restart, but you're welcome to enable
those on your own as well.
Now in your actual Unreal Engine scene, you have two different choices.
You can grab the Vcam actor, which is already set up to work with the Vcam app, or with
your standard Cine Camera actor, say you've already got a camera with all the settings
that you know you want to use, you can go ahead and add that Vcam component to get started
in the same way.
What we like about the Vcam actor is it already has the user interface that will be demonstrating
setup.
In either case, in order to access the details of our Vcam, we will actually have to navigate
down the hierarchy of our actor down to the Vcam PS for Pixel streaming component.
And this is where we will do things like set up our LiveLink subject to be our Vcam Pixel
streaming session.
A few of the standard setup elements once you've selected your Vcam component would be to hit
the checkbox to enable it.
If you have an active session, the LiveLink subject should automatically populate as your
Pixel streaming session.
And then you'll also want to hit the checkbox for lock viewport to camera to keep our Vcam
session active inside of the viewport.
Under output, you might already see UMG overlay populated, but this is where you could select
a different user interface besides the default one that we'll be reviewing.
Over on your mobile device, this is what you should see when the app boots up.
And here we are going to want to input our IPv4 address.
This can be found by opening your command prompt and typing an IP config or clicking
the drop down in your Pixel streaming menu in your viewport.
You'll also want to make sure that in the settings for the app that you have selected
Pixel streaming and not remote session.
At that point, if you hit connect, you should see a connection form between your computer
and your mobile device.
And you should see both your viewport in Unreal Engine and your mobile device screen matching
complete with the selected UMG.
Note that it may be necessary to uncheck and recheck the is active option in the output
tab in order for the app to begin tracking.
And if Pixel streaming does cause you any issues, you can set up a remote session either
with a Vcam app or with the Unreal Remote 2 app.
Similarly, you would enter your IPv4 address here and press connect.
If you have any issues, we have some troubleshooting steps.
First of all, make sure the virtual camera live link plugins as well as either the Pixel
streaming and or the remote session plugin are all enabled.
Next, make sure your iOS device and computer are directly connected to each other and sure
they're on the same Wi-Fi connection.
Make sure you're not using a signal repeater to confirm verify that both your iOS device
and computer are on the same public IP and you can do this by googling what's my IP to
get your public IP address.
And here's what I mentioned about using IP config in order to find your IPv4 address.
If you're connected to multiple networks, make sure you're looking at the right one.
For example, if you are connected to Ethernet, look for Ethernet.
And if you're connected to a wireless network, look for wireless.
Next verify that both devices are on the same subnet.
You will often notice a difference between something like a 192 subnet versus a 10.subnet.
So make sure, for example, that both your iOS device and your computer start with, for
example, 192.
And lastly, just verify that you did type in the correct IPv4 address inside the iOS
app.
If you do want to explore connecting via a remote session, there might be some additional
settings you have to configure in your project settings, plugins, UDP messaging.
You'll want to make sure that you find that IPv4 address and a few more troubleshooting
steps.
Make sure only one instance of Unreal is open.
Try disabling your firewall.
Try whitelisting devices and checking your firewall rules.
Verify that the app is on and actively capturing data.
And then my last and favorite step for all things broken, just try resetting or restarting
all devices involved and try again.
If you do not have access to an iOS device, there is a third party app made by By Owls.
A stripped down version similar to the Vcam plugin and it is available in the Epic Games
marketplace.
Just note that it is not free.
Next up, we'll take a look at the virtual camera's user interface.